now there are a few other features we'd
like to enable for our sound effects for
example whatever player and there's a
menu or switches to another tab we might
want to be able to cut out all sound
effects immediately in those
circumstances the way we do that is by
simply disconnecting our main node from
the node graph creating a new one in its
place and connecting it to our output
the new node won't be connected to any
of the sound effects the old one was so
we can start from a clean slate for the
next assignment we've provided a stop o
method for you to implement this
functionality you should be able to do
this in just a couple of lines of code